almost everyone who reads the borrowed
Among Us seems to love it despite the
story's bad reputation why is that the
manga began a year earlier than the
anime and retold the boruto movie that
had come out the year before and despite
the manga being monthly the anime began
a year later and then proceeded to do
nothing but anime only original content
for a year then it went back into filler
hell for two solid years because hey
oops they caught up again before then
finally adapting the next manga Arc with
insane visuals by the way then it was
forced into filler pain again and the
schedule died and nobody wanted to work
on it then after that it randomly
returned to the manga stuff and adapted
like 600 pages in seven episodes only to
suddenly end this series new king all
structure so yeah if you watch the
boruto anime in full you have been
robbed of a tightly structured and
coherent story and let's not even talk
about the production low points